Christina Cuomo just last week the wife
of CNN anchor Chris Cuomo revealed that
she too tested positive for Kovan 19 and
when I talked to Christina she described
to me the moment she knew something was
wrong I woke up without a sense of smell
or taste I woke up with such intense
explosive negative sinus energy and
doing everything I can to prevent it
from getting into my lungs
Christina's kovat 19 diagnosis was
actually a surprise at first she had
been so careful taking care of Chris
wearing gloves a mask and constantly
washing her hands so he is now out of
the basement and now he's upstairs in
the living room past those stairs is our
bedroom which is where I'm quarantined
to have my tea kettle I have my vitamins
and everything there he can engage with
the kids and help them again fly again
wasn't quitting like that but Christina
says her husband's friendly on air
bickering with his older brother New
York Governor Andrew Cuomo is what she's
seen at family gatherings for years
thank you for coming back to the show
mom told me I had to they're spirited
appearances have inspired hashtags like
Cuomo crush and even homosexual I have
someone sending me a sweater that says
that and then I had I mean it then we
should get some masks made right there
you go and oh yeah Christina's ready to
set up single brother-in-law Andrew I
put together a wait list Christina is
all about hope and positivity
she's a wellness guru and creator of the
online magazine the purest and she's
treating the virus with natural remedies
just like she did for Chris I have been
taking an incredible amount of vitamin C
vitamin d vitamin b6 quinine glutathione
said to you guys he sent Chris and me a
lot of vitamin packets some brain
boosting supplements things that I knew
to be really effective so basically
you're telling us that Ironman really is
Ironman Ironman yeah he sent us his
secret formula
[Music]